20 24 candidates okay
yeah eric do you have an opinion on this
on who do you think is going to be
2024 republican candidates
who do you think i think i would love to
see it
and and we'll see if it happens but dan
crenshaw and
uh tulsi gabbard vp a combination
and i think the republican side yes oh
no republican ticket dan crenshaw being
the vp i think would be because she's
she's you know pretty moderate and i
would like to see that happen i don't
know
too military by the way how did you come
up with that have you just been thinking
about it
i just thought of speculation i like
their personality i like that they're
logical somewhere or no
it's just me speculating i feel like
christian combination you just proposed
i i actually
uh fully kind of endorse where you're
going with this this is a republican
a reasonable moderate republican if you
guys don't know who dan cranshaw is
he's the guy with a patch on his eye uh
pete davidson on saturday live made fun
of the guy he had to retract that
a new policy now dan shaw crenshaw has
blown up by the way not a trump guy
crenshaw i mean he's voted with him in
congress yeah i think he's in the house
he's not a senator right who
he's a congressman congressman so he's
in the house uh not
he's not uh tone the company line so to
speak he's got his own opinions right
they're both congressmen
yeah and we'll tell uh tulsi gabbard is
no longer
um an active congresswoman she
i think she's no longer in office right
now
if you're watching this who do you think
who do you think 20 24 candidates i'm
curious i want to hear from you as well
who do you think
if you were to pick candidates in 2024
running who would be on your list but go
ahead you were saying something
no i i do like the fact i think this is
what this country needs a republican
uh you know a moderate republican a
moderate democrat coming together and
running under one ticket saying guys
we don't have to be so extreme it
doesn't need to go socialism
all the way to the left the aoc doesn't
need to be a candidate we don't need to
have a
you know what we won't call names but
whatever trump was doing
all the way to the right and you know
the the conspiracy theorists and the
queuing on and the
two like we need to again get back to
center paul what do you think
do you have anybody in mind uh well i've
heard about donald trump jr okay being a
a possible candidate
uh uh donald trump um
tulsi gabbard
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's your what's your good friend's
name uh juicy smoolay juicy sommelier
yeah
uh yeah mario who do you have anybody or
no not really
no idea do you know the odds no you know
the odds
you got yeah i got some give me
something i got some odds for you know
who is the highest
odds like most likely candidate nikki
haley who do you think it is the highest
odds
today best odds yes rand paul would be
another name
descendant this is listen gabard relax
who do you have as a highest
okay highest odds this is according to
uh
a betting website okay number one best
odds
you want to guess there's no way they're
going to have trump as the highest odds
you sure about that is he the highest
trump plus 800 as a wild card
plus eight hundred right so the the
lower your number the more likely so for
instance right now
you bet a hundred bucks you win 800
bucks exactly you know who the favorite
is who
in 2024 like the favorite you're gonna
tease me how much forward
i'm not talking i'm not
so the favorite right now to be
president in 2024 yeah
kamala harris plus 450. i'm with that
biden plus 600.
okay so meaning they project harris is
more likely to be president in 2024 what
is that
coffee okay it's a tea drink coffee
it's a tea oh it's a it's a london [ __ ]
okay come here you'll need a little soy
for that good buddy keep going so
somali is plus 450
nikki haley at plus 1200 mike pence
at plus 1600 and then we have
um ted cruz at plus 3300
senator josh hawley at plus 4 000
mark cuban plus 2500 so he's got better
odds
than cruz and haley as a republican as a
republican
uh your boy dan crenshaw plus 5 000
and your boy donald trump jr plus
5 000 so that is the most likely to
least
likely candidates and then you have gop
congresswoman marjorie taylor green
she's also the news
plus 10 billion she ain't going to be
president if you know who that is
yeah no before you better's out there
though so
let me let me give some names here let
me give some names here what you got
abbott okay one texas yes let me tell
you why
okay he's no he's done a good job doing
it forget about friends i'm saying he's
done a good job during okay
okay texas number one i would i wouldn't
put him number one i'm just saying
putting him on the list i know kai's got
a list here kai's got trump haley cruz
uh uh holly pants cotton
but i think abbott is one seriously to
consider
taxes i think the other one is desantis
let me tell you why
watch this um the nba
playoffs last year what was their main
campaign what would they campaign in
the entire time they're the nba bubble
and social justice or
what was it what was everybody wearing
everybody was wearing what social
justice
black lives matter yeah right okay so
a liberal organization decided to hold
their playoffs
in a conservative state ran by a
conservative republican desantis
right so the nba playoffs goes there
super bowl goes to florida they're right
now trying to bully japan saying if you
don't get your act together we will
gladly hold the olympics
yes in florida because we know how to do
it right so you
got to give credit to desantis right
okay and desantis is not a pushover
he's solid he can hang in there and he's
a pretty strong guy
and he's got good argument to give on
what they've done young guy too is
probably in his early 40s and watch this
can you imagine
if he does and somehow cuomo gets
involved
he will crush cuomo he's going to say
all your guys came to me
all your business people came to me so
that that would be a i'd love to see the
stage of cuomo going up against
desantis or seeing abbott going up
against newsom
i'd love if newsom runs and these guys
somehow get on the same stage
you know the other day we're watching
mcgregor we're watching mcgregor
fighting against i'm like what a week
i said what did i say to you you're so
pissed i was i'm like i don't even i
wasted my custody i was so disgusted by
it i wanted him to win you got a guy you
think you're gonna you're gonna anyways
it's just very frustrating this is
upsetting you i'm a fan i'm a fan but
the money you got a couple hundred
million dollars from proper 12
and you're going there either don't
fight or fight the guys he's so exciting
mcgregor i wanted khabib mcgregor and
that's not going to happen now khabib
made fun of him say this may never
happen again
yeah right and even dana said it may
never happen after what just took place
and then he had the drug stuff that came
up
which is six month suspension that's a
whole different story so drug stuff
uh connor connor had a uh uh yeah i
think conor got suspended kai can you
verify this i think kind of got
suspended for six months or something
like that yeah
so so so your sleeper is higher right
there yeah
you're a sleeper yeah you called mario
kai no i actually kai's texting oh
yeah you're basically saying your
sleeper is desantis
if you can pull off i think so so abbott
desantis pompeo i don't know if he's a
guy that could be a president
let me throw another curveball for you
let me throw another curveball for you i
don't know if it's going to happen this
year maybe it's going to happen in the
next eight to 12 years maybe 16 years
uh kushner's a genius ivanka i think
can run people love her and even the
left
respects her when she's saying kushner
or ivanka or you're saying that running
either or
either or because remember kushner is
not a republican kushner's a
center-right center sometimes
center-left
and ivanka is not fully a republican
ivanka's a center-right is where she's
at and she can go on the view and
they're very respectful to ivanka the
way she is right
so abbott desantis
trump uh ivanka kushner
tim scott which we've already talked
about i love what you said with tulsa
gabbard
dan crenshaw sure he hasn't had enough
publicity online
uh on media you know the whole thing
that happened with saturn online life
was good
i'm gonna throw a crazy curveball in
there crazy kerber because you know
the usual suspect everybody throws
here's a crazy one
that would be so interesting and by the
way i'd love to see cuban get in it
i'd like i told cuban there's four years
ago i told him four years ago and we
second i said i said so what's your you
know
i'd love to see i'd love to see him get
in it because i think
i think he pisses off both sides i don't
think cuban is a democrat i don't think
he's a republican
i think he is center left he's not a
republican but he center like
slightly like just a little bit left
okay is where he is at center left on
certain issues
center right on certain issues closer to
economy okay
but i don't know why i would love to see
tucker carlson run
tucker carlson you don't even know how
much i'd love to see him run
you don't know how bad i'd love to see
him run really i'd love to see him run
no support from the left oh zero yeah i
don't know if he's made no friends
well no wait a minute he's he's also
called out to trump he's called out the
right he's called out things that the
right has done so
you have to know that there's an element
of the right that also doesn't like
tucker so it's not like he is
he'll get up there and say stuff like
dude what are you doing are you a
republican or a democrat
uh what's her name really badly what's
her face the trump's lawyer the q anon
lady the
yeah yeah yeah yeah hardcore
i don't know who she was today what was
your latest
name sandy sydney sydney pound sidney
powell
he's the first one that was like yo
sydney show us the proof yeah you're
talking about big games you're talking
hugo chavez you're talking dominion yeah
a little bit too much so so
that's what i'm trying to tell you now a
billion dollars what i'm trying to tell
you is
i can see that you know if he was to get
it now here's a challenge why a guy like
that may not get in
you know why a guy like that may not get
in because a guy like that
is about to be a free agent and he's
probably going to land a hundred to 150
million dollar contract wow so him
running could cost him 150 million
money buddy that's probably what's gonna
end up happening the reason why some of
these guys like imagine bill o'reilly
never ran why maybe a little bit of
personal life i don't know
some of these guys never ran but you can
i think we've experienced that
there's a big difference between winning
you know your primary and the republican
party versus thank you baby
with the tucker carlson pick is uh a few
years back and this didn't end up a
success story but there's other names
that i can't come to my mind but
in the nfl uh matt millen who's a former
player yeah he was a color commentator
and then he had no front office
experience but then he jumped into
uh the gm role of the detroit lions but
to me that'd be kind of a similar thing
where it's like
you watch it and you're studying you're
analyzing it so you have a better maybe
understanding than a lot of
people from the from from inside so you
have a nice outside perspective but then
you don't necessarily
have all that experience but sometimes
that could work for you
so i kind of like that philosophy yeah i
don't know i like him
something about him i like you know like
like here's what's crazy
and people get upset when i say this
there's something about
uh chris come i like i don't know
there's something about
jon stewart i love i'm so glad he's back
on twitter by the way
jon stewart just got on twitter i don't
know if you guys heard it or not he's
officially on twitter he was never on
twitter
gets back on twitter and if you guys
have like go on his twitter account so
we can see what he says
you're a fan of john stewart i'm a fan
of jon stewart because i said he's
left he no he's not he's center left
he center left he called that nancy
pelosi on his show and made her look
like a fool
and he went up there and fought for the
firefighters from 9 11.
i don't know if he's left i don't know
if he's as left as you think he is i
think he's center left
but i think we need him i think i mean
go
go to twitter go type in john just type
in twitter on the top
no no just with jon stewart uh uh okay
go to twitter and type in john stewart
two t's ooh so you guys are in the same
community twitter
got it got it so kai
mario's making you look good today okay
yeah if you're watching you know kai
somewhere in omaha so he's kind of
somewhere right now he is celebrating
you said
you said type in uh go to his account
jon stewart
uh i'm not sure what it is
oh my gosh i can't believe somebody help
us out here go to maybe he's not on that
no he is
under he's 100 under he just he just has
a unique oh right there the
the dog all the way in the bottom all
the way that's him yeah believe we don't
have that same click on that okay one
million followers he's following one
person and the one person he's following
i think is wendy's i think
is it wendy's and he trashes them on a
tweet but go back
we have the tweet go back
okay so he puts up on the 31st i believe
compromise is the heart
and that out of progress demands
concessions so to the right in exchange
for universal healthcare i will uh
allow all the future mario what are you
doing i'm just reading mario what are
you doing i'll all future space leaders
to be non-denominational what compromise
do you propose remember there are no bad
ideas unity
the stuff he says yes i've come back on
you
much like one of your nasty nasty
sandwiches arby's right because arby's
said thanks for whatever so
if i do really well on here i get to be
president yes
he's got 485 yeah i think it's cool
though i think i think stuart
you know i enjoy his perspective i i i
don't know if
carson's gonna run or not but i think
that kind of a personality would be very
interesting but
eventually shapiro's gonna run yeah
eventually shapiro is going to run it
just may not be in the next 15 years
eventually he's going to i think i hear
that i think we would do a disservice if
we didn't address the
most likely leading contender other than
trump himself as nikki haley
she's a reasonable let's just let me
just read a little bit of what people
said here's what people said the sanders
and gnome okay tulsi and jocko
uh desantis and tulsi said amia madison
tulsi said dennis
mcgriff marilyn joseph says candace
owens
ian uh wins says patrick vedic 2024
how about patrick david soy boy pbd soy
boy campaign we gotta put that 20 24.
this will be here we got we got to make
sure we'll put our face on a milk carton
done
we'll get nancy on that right now face i
don't know yeah
okay tulsi tulsi tulsi says priyoman
roy chandley tulsi trump and tulsi trump
and tulsi
shapiron crowder uh
uh shapiro and crowd of mark cuban uh
doesn't matter who is president 2024.
and you've got ted cruz tulsi crenshaw
haley tim scott saying
tulsi has been demonized and ostracized
by the democratic party by the way this
is what's needed
meeting more people talking about you in
different platforms tulsi's makes made
herself
so relevant and different but people
want her this is very good it's good
time to have momentum because she's got
three years to create that kind of
momentum
it's actually a very good sign that
other people are saying this
uh uh uh who also got pbd and sauce
urban
jack okay so we got more anyways a lot
of people are saying you know different
names
but you said the leading candidate okay
one person here brando commander gave
five dollars and said i got republicans
matt gates
okay no way good looking guy you're not
a you're not a fan of matt gates i mean
he's shonda's cousin by the way so ted
cruz really josh hawley greg
abbott the sanders democrats kamala
harris newsom bob i grammar cuban
good list bob iger newsom when you say
someone like iger
say i'm thinking who can get out of the
primary and actually win the general
someone like bob iger can someone like
nikki can
okay tiger okay highly could be
president can
bob could be president yes and he wants
to by the way okay
democrats like him uh smart business guy
traditional conservatives you know i
don't know if he'll have the maga
community
nikki he's left okay yeah but his family
parents are left and he grew up wanting
to we've all seen you could do great
like ted cruz could do
great in the republican primary that
guy's never going to be president i'm
sorry
um matt gates you got to understand from
someone who
you know kind of views himself as center
left i'm looking at these names and i'm
saying there's no way matt gates is
ever going to be president united states
with the what he's done
and pissing off people on the left just
like someone like aoc is never going to
be president because no one on the right
would ever
vote for her so you need to have someone
who could
reach out to the other side and get
votes that's what trump was able to do
in 2016.
biden took some votes from trump in 2020
obama was able to do that in 2012.
big tent baby so ted cruz i don't see it
i don't see trump junior
i do see a nikki haley i do see
even a tom cotton i do see a tulsi
gabard
uh yeah i see what you did there yeah i
got a name for you guys
here we go this just started percolating
my head this is a little out there
but stop it he's got different
experiences which i like
ice cube i thought you were gonna say
john elway or something because of how
die hard of a guy you want ice cubes run
a business
he's he's in multiple platforms i got
someone for you he's a person kanye
kanye he's going to be he's going to be
the guy but ice cube is
is rational no and and he he's
he i think he grew up probably on the
left he's got more conservative
principles now
he's he's kind of all over the place
he's polarizing in a good way
you ain't got no job you only got no
place to go
it's friday ain't nobody gonna have i'm
gonna get you high today but i can see
that shirt though straight out of the
white house
straight out of the way i'm telling you
guys this is a marketing marketing
yeah marketing so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you